hallo mein name ist luca meiner liebe
freunde wir machen heute einen
lügendetektortest
ganz
schlimmen fragen
dafür hab ich selbstverständlich keine
kosten und mühen gescheut und für
siebeneinhalb 1000 euro dieses extrem
extrem
glaubhafte gerät erworben was du hast
mich das erste mal gesehen ist
das erst mal das nächste
jahr sind normal das mädchen alt
dann lieber nicht so
wichtig
ja du sagst aus dieser nacht mit seinem
outfit
trägt denn bei 30 grad alles egal hier
hast du in meiner anwesenheit schon mal
gefühlt ja
falsch
dieses gerät ist der absolute knüller
hast du schon mal was ein clown
klar
hier sehe ich ihn löffel damals
die situation ende alles stimmt ich habe
noch nicht aus geklaut aber ich habe das
nicht gegeben außerdem fehlten nicht
gegessen hast du schon mal in einen pool
[Applaus]
gebilligt du hast die finger zu früh
runter genommen das ist aber in der
natur geprüft
ja
jetzt will
der muss ja noch scan
richtig glück hast du im osten oft
abgeschrieben
ich glaube ich habe ab der 10 die kleine
aufgaben oder selber gemacht hab ich
eigentlich meint inso klausuren oder
soja dass auch ich habe noch später
dadurch habe ich meine ganze geschafft
hätte mir das foto bz bekannt ja ich
mache hat wo wir wirklich nicht
verstecken ich habe einfach bis 13 80
becker vorbereitet die ich ausgesucht
habe auf eine wasserflasche geklebt habe
und da alle sachen stehen hatte dass
kein schwein darauf gekommen wer von uns
beiden ist schlauer
als ich noch nicht über das
laut verpackung heißt das dass das spiel
nervös ist oder nur bei 30 schlauer bin
aber ich habe ja gesagt gewiss schlauer
sein können willst du nicht selbst das
handball beziehung
stammt wirklich witzig sein ließ einfach
machen unsere fragen keinen sinn warum
weil wir sagen so findest du sachen ich
muss mir sagen wer das witziger dann
wird man die wahrheit
[Musik]
also ich finde schon dass ich 40 bin
weil ich erstens besser aussehe und so
kann sehr groß und sehr kleine dran
liebe grüße von
warst du in einem streit schon mal
realisiert dass man falsch liegst aber
dann trotzdem weitergemacht
dieses gerät
48.000 euro gekostet es schon zwei mal
kaputt gegangen ist mal kurz überlegt
auf einem strauch drücken muss ist mir
aufgefallen
aber ich habe so fragen die buchsen und
wissen
vier millionen euro hat das ding
gekostet ist die shopping süchtig
leiblein kommt ganz einfach nicht okay
ich liebe dich
wärst du behauptest du multitaskingfähig
ich kenne wirklich keinen menschen der
weniger mit kassen
das hat sich mit seinen atom alarm ist
das gleiche profil in hamburg
reifenmarkt deine mutter dich oder deine
schwester lieber
gleich soll
[Musik]
denn da jetzt das herausgekommen was
man sagen
kann ja ja definitiv nein kann sie nicht
also ich wahrscheinlich jedes mal dann
schon mal ein spiel guck mal ich kann
mich gut fügen bei gegenüber knüpft so
schnell sachen dass ich mir ich kann mir
direkte sorry ausdenken frag mich wo ich
morgen bin
ich schon ich sage mir gleich einkaufen
ich muss aus schaffst du fünf
liegestütze
[Musik]
stimmig nicht das ist nicht wahr das ist
eine sache von sekunden das ist das ist
wow wow cool ich liebe dieses spiels du
eine gute autofahrerin
den beschluss
seine
bildzeile gutes
auto
du brauchst du führerschein auffrischung
die monatlich einfach hier wurde schon
geblitzt
wie viele gefahren bleiben sondern mit
den letzten 48 stunden gemacht
ich habe nein ich war gut ich kann doch
nichts dafür wenn einfach jemand drüber
fährt
es ist grün besser kochen
ich
du kannst du über zwiebel
scheiße herbert strg c das heißt wärst
du kannst es andere schneiden aber dafür
brauchst auch tutorials
du musst einmal drehen schneiden das war
fast du schon mal etwas mehr hunger und
kaputt gemacht als ich nicht da war
ich
bin
nein ich habe schon öfters bei dir aufs
feld gekommen ja da gibt sich michael
sowa und die schränke und die haben da
schon die hast du schon mal heiß gemacht
ja
schneller verarbeiten und so
habe ich noch nie gemacht an der stelle
habe ich das video allerdings jetzt auch
enden mit diesem extrem professionellen
lügendetektor meine lieben freunde für
das ding haben die 17 millionen euro
bezahlt wir haben unsere ganzen daten
auswerten lassen und geguckt ob wir
ehrlich sind oder unehrlich wenn es euch
gefallen und das kann einen downloader
die banker und klickt auf die blogger
weiter wie das nicht was auf einem zwei
kanal ihnen halt auch ein neues video
online
flugroute generieren
[Musik]
[Gelächter]